and with quantum physics the rules of  flicking a little particle and seeing  where it goes are so wonky that you will  you won't know where that particle goes  it might tunnel through a barrier the  plant on your wall could just move  through the wall all of a sudden those  types of things happen on the quantum  scale so weird things happen and you  need special math to describe those  weird behaviors so that's quantum  physics and then over here is  the opposite so it's the opposite of  like something really tiny would be  something really really big something  big enough to noticeably affect  this the curvature of space and time  those are things like  black holes the sun neutron stars  supernovas like the most massive things  in the universe are described by the  language of general relativity and we  still have not been able to unify those  there's some places where the languages  don't match